après cet entretien en particulier avec
son futur chef pierre puciers va passer
la visite d'incorporation dire puciers
est un soldat moyens c'est aussi un cas
limite les mariés et pères de famille et
d'ailleurs si le projet de réforme du
service militaire est adopté par les
députés
il y a de fortes chances pour que les
gens dans sa situation soit dispensée de
servir sous les drapeaux
en attendant puissiez lui va servir
il est reconnu apte par les médecins du
quatrième chasseurs
de là il va suivre la chaîne son côté
civil et dans sa valise il le remettra
dans 16 mois
il s'agit maintenant de faire rentrer
son mètre soixante dix neuf et 197 de
tour de poitrine dans un uniforme seyant
il chausse du 45 mais on a dû 45
aux jambes
cadouin droit
ces 25
gratuite pour le groupe
79 terminée
l'essayer vous toute l'école
passé par tôt
midi l'anti non pas à la roulante mais
au seul service
après midi de la 2e journée abc du
métier des armes le garde-à-vous le
repos la marche au pas le port du béret
commandement pensez vous que le service
militaire puisse vous apporter quelque
chose on va pas je ne pense pas bien que
tout le monde dise quand on a fait le
service militaire on n'éteint pas ce
qu'on a fait le service militaire pour
mon corps je croque le service malin
militaire m'apporte quelque chose est-ce
que vous pensez que ça a beaucoup changé
par exemple avec la vie militaire qu'a
pu connaître votre père a certainement
oui la vie militaire d'aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup plus améliorée on ne serait ce
que par les tenues l'est pourquoi
avez-vous sourire parce qu'en principe
la tenue militaire est toujours réputé
pour je parle pas de la vareuse mais
surtout port du pantalon
on peut pas qualifier tellement
esthétique et qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la discipline discipline alors là
j'ai été très étonné par la discipline
enfin c'est le commencement mais c'est
ca sert loges pour ma part dans le temps
le groupe où je suis j'ai un brigadier
qui est très aimable
or on du tout militaire
c'est un appelé c'est un appelé oui
et les autres officiers des officiers
les officieux hausse pour le peu qu'on
les a rencontrées jusqu'à présent ils
sont très sympathiques
enfin en principe ils le font pour
accueillir leur le client le client mais
est-ce que par la suite à pourra changer
certainement en mer - ras bord nous on a
une bonne impression